9-1-1 quelle est ton urgence
bonjour es-tu là
mec j'ai frappé quelqu'un
et je l'ai laissé je l'ai laissé là
oh mon dieu ne dis à personne
que jamais je ne peux le faire je peux te garder en
sécurité si personne n'en entend jamais parler
le garçon que tu m'as frappé ce matin est
le fils de jimmy baxter
le chef de la famille criminelle la plus vicieuse
de la ville
qui que tu sois où que
tu sois tu seras trouvé
j'ai besoin d'une faveur sans poser de questions
[Musique]
nous allons grand nous allons grand une fois
mon  le meilleur ami vient de me jeter dans le grand
bain j'ai ça
je ne pense pas que tu l'
aies [Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon
je te promets que ça va aller